we're going to begin this hour with a
behind the scenes look at the new
historical Epic film it's called the
woman King the action film starring
Viola Davis and John boyega topped the
box office earlier this month becoming
just a second film directed by a black
woman ever to open it number one you go
Gina Anthony Mason met up with that
director that would be Gina Prince
vicewood at Noya house workspace and in
her Los Angeles office where he Anthony
got to set in on an edit session just
weeks before the film's release Anthony
that's so cool good morning to you it
was pretty cool Gail good morning Gina
Prince bethelwood is often cited as an
inspiration for a new generation of
black female creators like Eva Duvernay
and Issa Rae the woman King's already
generating Oscar buzz but she was
working right down to the wire to finish
the film
[Music]
the woman King
after shooting her epic action film The
Woman King over 63 days in South Africa
director Gina Prince bikewood was back
in LA in late August screening footage
with editor Terry Shropshire
putting together the directors Extended
Cut so this is how the dance starts I
think a lot of people would be surprised
that here we are with two and a half
weeks from the premiere and you're still
working on this I'm still working
everyone keeps looking at each other
like houses how's this happening
a storyboard in the edit room lays out
every scene in the film when you look at
this it doesn't seem like
a huge thing and so that's really
helpful in in the early stages when
you're kind of trying to filmed well
that's a good one the films consumed a
year and a half of her life
based on true events the woman King is
the story of the agoji an all-female
unit of Warriors who protected the
kingdom of Dahomey I think so many of us
have an image of what Africa was like in
the 1800s and it wasn't this this was
the only Kingdom in Africa where women
had a voice in the government it's only
the sixth film for the 53 year old
director it seems to me you've chosen
the films that you've made very
carefully
why'd you pick this one
as soon as I read maybe five pages it
was a guttural connection I had never
heard about these women before and I
think about
what I needed as a young black girl
growing up as a young girl growing up
growing up in California Prince
spythwood was a basketball star in high
school a track star in college and an
Avid Reader you said once I think that
the reason you liked stories was you
could control the ending yeah there was
just growing up I needed
something to take my mind off of
negative things in my life and that's
why I love books so much to disappear
into that Principe would was adopted and
raised in a predominantly white
neighborhood she struggled with
self-esteem and racism in school I was
always reminded she said of my otherness
and then when I started writing it it
really was wow I can I can write a happy
ending and there's a
there's a great power in that she was
accepted at UCLA but not into the
program she dreamed about initially you
you were rejected from the film School
I'd say I hear that it's like what do
you relive the pain or what it was it
literally
there's like three horrible moments in
my life and getting that rejection
letter was one of them it was
devastating I felt like your life it's
like what am I supposed to do now she
made an impassioned appeal to the head
of the school and they reversed their
decision and that changed my life
on graduating in 1991 she landed a
writing job on the TV series a different
world where she met her husband Reggie
rockbighthood but later quit TV to write
her first screenplay he spent a year and
a half yeah a half unloving basketball
yes and nobody wanted it there's
crickets
a player rejected by every Studio One
game one-on-one
for what
touching your heart until Sundance
stepped in in 2000 her directorial debut
Love and Basketball was finally released
a romantic comedy she'd envisioned as a
black When Harry Met Sally Dublin
nothing
how does it feel all these years later
with that movie now
viewed by many as a classic it never
gets old when somebody comes up and says
that they love that film
that's the queen she'd follow it with
The Secret Life of Bees my job is
stressful enough I don't mean it's my
personal life Beyond the Lights
the Old Guard the first comic-based
Blockbuster to be directed by a black
woman how would you describe yourself as
a director
um
wow
Bernie Mac called you the quiet storm
that was cool actually someone used an
example on on this film they said it's
like a duck we're on the surface on this
but underneath the water they know like
sweeter than that you have the ability
to actually change the way people see
yeah my body of work
100 is about changing The Narrative of
black women
in the woman King General daniska played
by Viola Davis is a machete wielding
badass this is the actual prop from the
film this this is it this is naniska's
second machete she keeps it in her
office you're gonna have a souvenir this
is the one to have that was the first
thing I asked for
the fight scenes are very elaborately
choreographed
hard is that to do you want it to be
choreographed so no one gets hurt but
you want them to also have the freedom
to improvise a little bit you want to be
able to be there and capture those those
magical moments the cast trained on
weights weapons and in the martial arts
this narrative that people still have
that women are not Warriors that are not
Fighters that are not strong
if they were on this set it would blow
their minds how tough
these women were
the director herself trained with them
one last thought how has being an
athlete
affected your attitude towards all this
do you think
that athlete mentality drives the way I
direct directing takes incredible
stamina yeah which is what you learn as
Natalie takes incredible fight
incredible belief in yourself
yeah being an athlete has been
everything
yeah I think Anthony persistence is a
big part of that too it's so interesting
that aspect and you know she gave up
basketball scholarships to apply to UCLA
because she wanted to get in the film
School ultimately and of course was
rejected and you saw how devastating
that was how did she word the letter
herself that's what I want to know yeah
that's what I wanted to know and she
doesn't have the letter anymore she said
she wished she did but she basically
wrote and said you've made a mistake I
was meant to do this I have a story to
tell and no one else is telling it I've
admired her and she was absolutely right
by the way I have admired her for so
many years but to see that interview
with her and its totality how smart she
is yes how talented she is how
persistent she is it just makes you
think she is in a different category is
and Anthony you tapped into some of the
things that she struggled with as a
child is what motivates her as a
director right now yeah and you see it
all come out in her films and the movie
is good yeah it's good I didn't know
that she had trained too
yeah she's in it all right Anthony thank
you very much it's a great piece